good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson son happy Monday one of the
great unsolved mysteries of the past
four years is why certain types of
people with certain types of jobs hate
Donald Trump so much really hate him
obsess over him think about him when
they wake up in the morning would hurt
him if they could what a fixation
it has nothing to do with the reasons
that normal people sometimes get annoyed
with Trump the bragging the short
attention span the rants on Twitter
none of that justifies hatred or
obsession plenty of politicians have
unappealing personal qualities Teddy
Kennedy killed a woman and he's still a
hero to the Democratic Party know the
reason the ruling class despises Donald
Trump is because they can't control him
Trump throws the bit he refuses to mouth
their lyrics he will not obey at any
moment Donald Trump is liable to come
out with something that you're
absolutely not allowed to say borders
make countries for example China is our
enemy Whoopi Goldberg
isn't that funny all of it undeniably
true and that's the point and the
problem Trump's words hang in the air
for all to see and to assess and they
are therefore a massive threat to people
whose livelihoods depend upon fraud and
lying Trump is the most dangerous to his
enemies when he tells the truth in fact
there is enemies precisely because
sometimes he does tell the truth and he
did the other day on Friday the
president gave a speech at Mount
Rushmore
he spoke eloquently about the BLM riots
and what they mean for the country
here's part of it baked no mistake this
left-wing Cultural Revolution is
designed to overthrow the American
Revolution in so doing they would
destroy the very civilization that
rescued billions from poverty disease
violence and hunger and that lifted
humanity to new heights of achievement
discovery and progress to make this
possible they are determined to tear
down every statue symbol and memory of
our national heritage our national
heritage
it's something we can be proud of this
country defeated both fascism and
communism our revolution inspired
Democratic revolutions around the world
from South America to India even today
pro-freedom demonstrators in Hong Kong
where the stakes are very high
waved the American flag to express their
hope and their defiance our economy and
our schools created the world's first
and the greatest educated middle class
our engineers and our scientists invents
the airplane and the transistor and
virtually everything else in modern life
they also transformed agriculture they
ended famine on most of the globe our
richest citizens became famous not for
the palaces they built to themselves but
for the philanthropy they gave to others
Andrew Carnegie built countless
libraries for the poor john d
rockefeller eradicated hookworm in the
south these are not the deeds of an evil
country they are the accomplishments of
a great country yet as the president
pointed out Americans school children
learned virtually none of this instead
our curricula have become a toxic mix of
Lies and omission all of it designed to
poison our children against the country
that formed them against every law of
society in nature our children are
taught in school to hate their own
country and to believe that the men and
women who built it we're not heroes but
that were villains the radical view of
American history is a web of lies all
perspective is removed every virtue is
obscured every motive is twisted every
fact is distorted and every flaw is
magnified until the history is purged
and the record is disfigured beyond all
recognition every word of that is true
if you have kids in school you know it
may even be understatement what is
happening in our classrooms right now in
2020 is a crime it is long past time
that a sitting president said so and
then Trump kept going toward the end of
his speech
defended the core promise of America the
principle this country was founded on is
the only principle to allow America to
survive going forward a nation where all
citizens are equal from birth and as a
result enjoy equal rights and equal
protection under the law
it's the America our Declaration of
Independence describes we believe in
equal opportunity equal justice and
equal treatment for citizens of every
race background religion and create
every child of every color born and
unborn is made in the holy image of God
we want free and open debate not speech
codes and cancel culture we embrace
tolerance not prejudice we support the
courageous men and women of law
enforcement
we will never abolish our police or our
great Second Amendment which gives us
the right to keep and bear arms we
believe that our children should be
taught to love their country honor their
history and respect our great American
flag we stand tall we stand proud and we
only kneel to Almighty God this is who
we are this is what we believe and these
are the values that will guide us as we
strive to build an even better and
greater future we almost never place
sound bites that are that long
politicians rarely give speeches worthy
of it most what they say is garbage and
we don't want to repeat it but Friday's
address at Mount Rushmore was probably
the best the single best speech Donald
Trump has ever given it was a road map
for his reelection message but more than
that it was a road map for the country
itself a quality decency pride in our
nation those were the themes naturally
the liars on television deeply hated
every word of it there was really a myth
of America that this idea that America
treated people well that they
treated men and women equally that that
we founded this country just by our own
wits that that is actually a line much
of American political propaganda over
the course of our history has tried to
completely erase ignore lie about the
dog Lee parts of our history Mount
Rushmore isn't exactly the innocent Oh
to our founding fathers as described in
our textbooks and it's high time we
disrupt that false narrative that far
too many people believe here we are
celebrating the birth of a nation
independence for white men at a site
described by one Native American
activists as quote a symbol of white
supremacy if you spent the rest of your
life trying to locate to identify the
worst people in this country of 330
million you couldn't get a pure
distillation than what you just saw
these people are liars they're the same
people who spent the last month telling
you that the riots you saw live on
television we're actually peaceful
protests against racism that was a lie
they knew it was a lie when they said it
but they said it anyway in order to
undermine a country that they hate yes
hey America deserves to be in flames
that is their view and this weekend they
said it essentially out loud Mount
Rushmore they told us must go it is
illegitimate
just like the nation it celebrates
President Trump will be at Mount
Rushmore where he'll be standing in
front of a monument of two slave owners
and on land rested away from Native
Americans with these founding fathers
with these monuments that we don't want
to forget what do we do with them maybe
they don't stand in the Town Square
which should they stand anywhere should
we demolish them it's been polluted it's
been desecrated by putting these
slave-owning racist horrible horrible
white men in 60-foot statues on this
wall when you look at this place this
land the Black Hills the history is a
dark one but it's not just the land that
had been stolen in a place like Mount
Rushmore in the Black Hills it's the the
theft of history the theft of the
narrative is worth reminding folks that
the man who caught
the monument behind me had deep ties to
the KKK the mother of all photo ops
Mount Rushmore and we know why this
president just can't resist going there
so about Rushmore is now a symbol of
evil just like your nation where's this
all going as writer Matt Taibbi put it
quote CNN even put independence in
quotes when describing the holiday this
will end with Wolf Blitzer dressed in a
dashiki pulling the switch to dynamite
the Statue of Liberty end quote pretty
funny but suddenly it's getting easier
to imagine that happening on the morning
of July 4th the Washington Post
summarized the President's speech the
one clips of which we displayed this way
quote president Trump's unyielding push
to preserve Confederate symbols and the
legacy of white domination crystallized
by his harsh denunciation of the racial
justice movement Friday night at Mount
Rushmore has unnerved Republicans who
have long enabled him for real that was
not an opinion piece by the way on the
op-ed page it was a news story written
by two Washington Post reporters they
described the president's defense of
equality under the law as quote Trump's
push to amplify racism jeff bezos his
newspaper local politicians joined the
chorus the mayor of Nashville cancelled
the city's fourth of July fireworks but
allowed BLM protests to continue
unimpeded in Richmond city officials
ordered a construction site to remove an
American flag it was too provocative
they said meanwhile the statue of mass
murderer Vladimir Lenin stands totally
unmolested in the City of Seattle
tonight officials they are seeing
nothing provocative about it so where's
Joe Biden on all of this as the
revolution continues apace Biden is
supposed to be a moderate remember that
was his chief appeal but there was
nothing moderate about Biden's fourth of
July statement instead it was a
full-throated attack on the United
States our country was founded on an
idea we hold these truths to be
self-evident
we've never lived up to it Jefferson
himself didn't he held slaves women were
excluded American history is no fairy
tale it's been a constant push and pull
between the two parts of our character
the idea that all men and women all
people are created equal and the racism
that has torn us apart we have a chance
to rip the roots of systemic racism out
of this country that's your fourth of
July message systemic racism something
you can't even define that has no real
definition really wagging your finger in
the face of the nation that promoted
someone is mediocre as you to the
position you currently hold this is the
man who could soon be our figurehead but
how about the actual presidential
candidate whoever Biden picks as his VP
running mate
senator Tammy Duckworth of Illinois is a
top contender for the job you're not
supposed to criticize Tammy Duckworth in
any way because she once served in the
military
most people just ignore her but when
Duckworth does speak in public you're
reminded what a deeply silly and
unimpressive person she is
here's Tammy Duckworth from over the
weekend telling us it's time to get rid
of George Washington I know that you
support changing the name of military
bases named after Confederate leaders
but there are leaders like George
Washington and Thomas Jefferson who were
slave owners and some people are
demanding that their monuments come down
too so in your view where does it end
should statues for example of George
Washington come down well let me just
say that we should start off by having a
national dialogue on it at some point a
national dialogue please they're not
looking for any colloquy what they want
is a soliloquy we speak you shut up and
listen so what a make of all of this
well it's long been considered out of
bounds to question a person's patriotism
it's a very strong charge and we try not
ever to make it but in the face of all
of this the conclusion can't be avoided
these people actually hate America
there's no longer a question about that
and yet paradoxically at the same time
they desperately want to control America
more than anything and that leads to the
most basic of all questions can you
really lead a country that you hate ask
yourself what kind of pair
would you be if you hated your children
what kind of officer would you make if
you didn't care about your troops it
would be awful the results would be ugly
it would not work loving the people you
lead caring deeply about them is the
most basic prerequisite of leadership
the leaders of today's democratic party
do not they despise this country they
have said so they continue to that is
shocking but it is also disqualifying we
cannot let them run this nation because
they hate it imagine what they would do
to it